to several years ago when the youth
council first heard about the
redevelopment of Essex Street they
suggested that at the same time Essex
Street could go smoke-free and so each
youth council since then has discussed
it and agreed that it's still a good
idea and so right now today we're doing
a survey to see what the people think
about a smoke-free esque Street the
youth council decided to do it because
it was all very well for them to think
it was a good idea but what about the
people the people are the ones who has
shop in the street who walked down the
street who are going to enjoy the new
places to sit and Rick create and so
they needed to ask them and make sure
that other people thought it was a good
idea also so this is purely a snapshot
in time so it's what is a wednesday
lunch time and it's what those people
think and so we'll be reporting to this
council next year and telling the
council what people thought today about
this idea of having a smoke free disk
street we're aware that the pho has also
done some research and talked to
retailers and so we're going to put the
information together and say well this
is what the retailers think and this is
what some of the people think if people
are interested they could go on to the
youth council facebook page and have
their say via that would be really
useful well in the city we already have
spoke free parks and reserves and
playgrounds and so you know there's
other places and throughout New Zealand
we haven't really looked but I'm sure
there are areas throughout New Zealand
that are just as innovative as in
Picardy leurs so I'm sure it's there we
certainly heard from one lady just now
that it's an Australia and she said it's
just wonderful she really enjoys that
particular city just because it's got so
many smoke-free streets so people that
we've spoken to so far
I really keen on the idea we've had very
few negative comments even people that
are smokers are in favor it's not like a
nice thing I've ever yeah it doesn't
really access but do you think they
should be a band of smoking on a string
yes duty find that affects your shopping
experience if someone is smoking around
you know it's kinda six one-half dozen
the other really like I don't really
mind that much but like there's kids
walking down the road I'm probably you
know quite my singing because it's
common courtesy but if they did ban it
on esque street with that affect your
shopping here at all no I'm still smoke
down here too to be honest what's your
opinion on people smoking on East Street
um I don't think they should smoke on
East Street just cause everyone's out
here and no because their own shopping
that um yeah just personally but I guess
it something that everyone does so I
can't really get rid of it